yeah man Utah why yeah what you looking
pretty cute this morning I mean you're
looking at me like the sweater where'd
you get that it's not a sweatshirt as
it's sweater from roots from when it's
on sale from roots yet on Phil yeah why
he looks snuggly is Wow it is now you
look snugly now what do you mean
oh no it's Turkey what why Turkey
I'm not a you looking at me like I'm a
piece of Turkey bro nah bro
you look super snugly yeah I'm snugly
but don't say slightly old warm and snug
that's disconcerting to me because
you're a giant man so don't want to grab
you know I don't coddle me I can't move
mm-hmm
you can't come in here just in a snuggle
sweatshirt no setting the world record
for the hardest punch first of all I saw
this going around I've seen the bring up
that video chin where's the rack but we
mean world record how many people
entered and what do you hit how's this
work the YouTube video right there you
go I just saw it oh well that's breaks
world record I don't with the other one
but video chain where see that right
yeah and fan sites pretty legit oh it's
Instagram yeah today we're here at the
UFC Performance Institute and we're
gonna be working with Francis and Ghanim
measuring the punching power they
displayed in his fight against Olaf ski
but also what he's done these recent
fights
today we're going to be looking at the
overhand right which is the most
powerful punch for Francis and also the
off-balance uppercut see how he can
demonstrate forced an explosion in
difficult on authorization what this is
going to allow us to do is understand if
he can maintain power and force output
in a less than ideal body position when
he's off balance though mazing results
today
Francis demonstrate a punching power
just over one hundred twenty nine
thousand units that's higher than the
previous record of 114,000 demonstrated
by kickboxer Tyrone Spong
suppose the monster is recording ever
not only here in the performance
Institute but around the world
damn why and you know who else like did
Mike Tyson hit that thing did aunty
Joshua hit that thing did Alistair
Overeem give a shot at it Conor McGregor
did a lot of these other punchers young
you should have every fighter hit that
I'm sure they've had a [ __ ] load because
it's the the the UFC Institute so I'm
sure ton have maybe I don't know i'd
like i'd only hit that [ __ ] thing
when i don't get hurt when you were
fighting did you have that know the USC
institute wasn't there when I was there
motorcycle you just you doing everything
what if you want you hit someone's
window with your [ __ ] gear on kids
keep going give them a little start
bunch of mirrors wave and keep going
sorry I'm Dallas running the scary stuff
is though when they don't see you yeah
that's the bra your boy Juan has maybe
got the worst years I've ever seen on a
human being I mean in other words just
they look very very whether those are
the worst yeah there might be yeah this
one looks like good poorly knee his just
look like I mean they're just enclosed
but this he's like Hans is that real
hard work job which is like rubbing it
you know trying to get out go home and
do it he wanted he wanted to have one of
it he wanted a tough guy Oh take it
alone look in pliers and hear your ears
have held up pretty much I mean not
really he's got he's got cars a bit of
it yeah yeah do you have to get
initiated in for one of those uh bayonet
patches yeah man he's got to be [ __ ]
pretty cool if he crazy ha you know of
my new tattoo
we hear the Hat doing that non [ __ ]
stuff is no place to pull an 80 foot
trailer and idea bad I do know that
though so something's happening with my
RV beep beep [ __ ] sirens going off
we're pushing it you can't drive 90
miles an hour just the gas pedal goes
all by the floor but they don't
recommend you just keep it there right
so that's how I Drive it and so of
course we [ __ ] the engine up somehow
on our way here and so what we're having
this problem now we got to go to the
studio because the studio told us that
we can park there that's where and I
said I'm not driving in LA out of state
somewhere else and rode the bikes in not
only got a spot for you so hold him the
guy's directing us you know how you
getting those studios are tight yeah oh
yeah so of course we take out a couple
things couple things got a brand-new
trailer kinda smashed oh we have an each
side of the building no oh man oh I just
swing the guy's dragna's it I take a
left tray that you know when you turn
hard yeah box out so it caught this how
about the trailer is there a lunch tub I
mean buff out then did all you guys jump
out and like all right well then we had
like Dario's it took it took literally
probably three hours to like forward
back I felt like I was Austin Powers
turning the [ __ ] golf three percent
but 80 feet with a trailer so I got a
turn left to back it up right you know
and then fix it with all this movie
stuff everything about moving to LA
cowboy so no [ __ ] no so then we torture
they would do the thing and then they're
like yeah you guys can't stay here I
said so what the [ __ ] was that about why
do we what they told you you couldn't
stay there and then he says I need your
insurance information so we can not damn
bill you day I met my wedding I had
friends like this at my wedding we were
at the Ojai Valley Inn and Spa really
nice [ __ ] beautiful place and I got a
lot of degenerate friends you understand
so all of a sudden the wedding planner
comes running up to me she goes there's
a problem I go as just your huge friend
is about to fight the security guards
and
why so I go running out into the parking
lot and my friends who don't have a lot
of money one of them very big guy hello
my buddy Frank you don't know him but
Frank Martin who's has a unfortunately
now a brain tumor that's about um but
he's a hothead and a great guy but but
he and my other buddy Johnny and Steve
shocker decided you know what we're
gonna drive a lot of huge RV into the
parking lot of this very exclusive spa
ramble and not only gonna stay there but
oh by the way we're also gonna we're
also gonna pull out an umbrella and
we're gonna fry up some fun dogs on our
hibachi what's wrong our hip hockey
what's wrong I go [ __ ] Frank and him art
that this huge security guard Frank is
six seven and they're bumping chests
while there's blubbers [ __ ] a my
writing I go on my friend get you
[ __ ] RV get into [ __ ] on what planet
do you think this is all right I know
cooking cooking burgers
guys why not cook your own burger when
you use this wet food the guys don't
resorts that guys like you can't do this
my mother maybe yes we do maybe he yeah
cooks a six-star burger I agree with he
probably does
Oh hides me tough it's tough